the you know the entire world of every  science fiction novel and story ever  written is minuscule compared to the  universe's of strangeness and  peculiarities that are accessible to any  one of us if you will but apply the  method and if you're not willing to  apply the method then you know you're  gonna sweep up around the ashram so hell  freezes over and not understand what is  going on  I mean I think you know I'm sorry to be  so hard on religion I think it has its  place it's places the inspiration of the  of ethical behavior you know religion  should teach ethical behavior but it has  very very little to say about the  mystery of being other than that it's  there and that's not practicing religion  practicing religion is Dancing with the  mystery losing and finding yourself in  the mystery  [Music]